[Música]
y vino
mi vida cambió radicalmente gracias
cuando empecé
el bachillerato en artes y humanidades
edad que es de bellas artes del inba
a los 14 años entre y en el primer
semestre de apreciación musical el
maestro llegó un día con un disco de una
cantante de jazz increíble la mejor que
ha habido y la mejor que hay y la mejor
de todos los tiempos y si ustedes la
escuchan estoy segura que vamos a
coincidir en la opinión la ficción
bueno ella se caracteriza por tener una
voz super ultra virtuosa y por dominar y
llevar al máximo esplendor un estilo
vocal en el jazz que se llama scat
singuen
que fue inventado por louis amstrong
trompetista y cantante antes que ella
pero ella lo llevó lejos y nadie la ha
podido superar que es el scat singing es
inventar melodías en una banda orquesta
trío dúo de jazz como si la voz fuera un
instrumento más y bueno es a través de
un concepto estético de basado en
sílabas de onomatopeyas que no pueden
ser cualquiera no podemos cantar popurrí
saab dicha papada youtube y no o sea
tiene que estar dentro del concepto
estético y dentro de la armonía de la
canción y del lenguaje de ellas como él
lo hacía perfectamente y para ejemplo
para identificar un perfecto escape
singing transcribe 12 vueltas de un
estándar de jazz muy conocido de duke
ellington que se llama the train
[Música]
y mire
mira
[Música]
y para mí
pero no
es un pescado perfectamente bien
estructurado hecho ha inventado por en
la ficción ella no lo escribió nadie lo
escribió para ella no lo estaba leyendo
en el momento ya lo improviso ya lo
inventó y por eso fue la pionera del
scat singing
digo que me cambió la vida porque tenía
14 años a esa edad yo escuchaba lo que
todo adolescente de 14 años escucha es
decir reggaetón banda pop y escuchar a
ella en ese disco haciendo todo y
embaladas en el casting en swing fue
fue un parteaguas en mi vida y de ahí
decidí dedicarme a esto e investigar más
acerca de otras cantantes acerca de
otros músicos de jazz y sobre el género
jazz y me topé con otra cantante que se
llama sar von
que es de mis favoritas y es también de
mis principales influencias
no hacía no se dedicaba tanto al escape
singing a mí lo que me llamó la atención
de sarah fue su super duper
tesitura su registro alcanzaba desde el
2 más agudo de una soprano hasta el rey
más grave de una contralto y esos graves
fueron los que a mí más me llamaron la
atención porque vivos tiende más a ir
hacia los graves que hacia los agudos es
decir por naturaleza desarrolló mejor
los graves que las notas agudas
entonces a esa edad esos graves de
zalamea llamaron mucho la atención
sara se caracterizaba por llevar el
ritmo en toda una big band o un trío de
jazz
al grado que el baterista solo rozaba
por encimita con las escobetas los
platillos y los tambores
vamos a
es simplificar basándonos inspirándonos
en sabón y en su estilo un estándar muy
conocido de facto a lo que se llama
jalisco rose
22 el oro perdía el oro pero díaz vería
por ver vía mir y fijar vía del sueño
así puedo decir vamos mi linda bilmes
nombres
[Música]
insight
con snow
a niza kalou
[Música]
michael normal
uy
bueno quien se expandió 6 de los tips de
philips y confecciones no
[Música]
y bueno esta micro investigación que me
llevó a hacer el afiche
me
encontró con otra cantante una diva para
mí ella son unas divas porque ser diva
va más allá de tener fama dinero éxito
belleza glamour
eso es una viva esto es ser una diva
ella es billy holliday
y a diferencia de sara y de él a su voz
era dulce era aguda pero su estilo era
muy emotivo muy conmovedor cada nota que
bill y ejecutaba estaba llena de
melancolía
y para prueba de ello como inspiración
digo no como una invitación y como
influencia vamos a
a tocar mi balada favorita que se llama
i'm confe singh para el obvio
y tú
haim con fe sin dar el novio
ya me dije a michel
una confesión
caray niña
ay
ni se mueve y mande
y yo
hybrid sunstein state
botti slip sinaí
jay chou
[Música]
efe
sí
a mí en mi plan
[Música]
jamás frei
jamie heaslip min
ya no es el ife
y yo no fui
p
baby
amaya sin decirlo
yo y mi prima facie
[Música]
ah
pesic try lo di
[Música]
quieres
[Aplausos]
[Música]
esto que les comparto lo hago porque yo
creo que soy un ejemplo de por qué
conformarme con lo que la sociedad me
dice que tengo que escuchar y que me
tiene que gustar porque está de moda
y además es algo súper efímero que la
moda pasa y qué tal artista pasa y no
trascendió porque tengo que conformarme
con eso porque no voy más y eso pasó
cuando y ese disco de la felicidad y
sigue pasando porque sigo estudiando y
sigo descubriendo nuevas cosas
y para ya finalizar dentro de esos
nuevos descubrimientos que he tenido
pues está la anécdota de que iba en un
número en la ciudad de méxico
y el chofer tenía pues el reggaeton a
todo lo que da y me dice señorita le
cambió la estación y yo por favor
cambiarles ya y la primera que puso fue
pues una estación de ellas que a mí me
gusta mucho y estaba por terminar un
estándar de fachada
que estaba olvidado y que no ha sido
rescatado por nadie excepto por una de
las nuevas divas del jazz que ella es
actual ella está viva y es joven se
llama catherine rosell y lo interpretó
de la siguiente forma
enríquez lluis a acompañar muy bien el
sabil cast
[Música]
baby
de la calle
haciendo tráfico
efe
viví en china online
adiós amor
te mentí
[Música]
eso no quiere decir vivir como ya que es
mala
[Música]
estilo ingenieril impiva
this cannabis
es una figura que la lleve porque aquí
es conocido tráfico cuidarme uip y que
debe hacerse
busqué a mi amigo y yo lo estoy en medio
de vivir en china
búscame odioso
mente
[Música]
la huella deslinde nada quiere destruir
mi mente
[Música]
[Aplausos]